all right welcome back everyone to my
round seven recap from the Reykjavik
open this was by far my craziest game of
the tournaments and I was playing
against a player by the name of Tobias
Becker from Germany rated 2085
and as we're going to see in this game I
really wanted to win and I took a lot of
risks the game started with a Sicilian
uh we went into an accelerated Dragon
which is an opening I've been playing a
bit more often recently and especially
against lower rated opponents I found it
to be a nice weapon to get more Dynamic
positions from early on so my opponent
played the Marathi bind which is C4
and from here there's two main options
for black there's starting with Bishop
G7 and there's Knight F6 and the moves
are sometimes transposing but there are
some differences and here I choose to
start with that F6 uh attacking the pawn
on e4 and after Knight to C3 I play Pawn
to D6 and the idea of delaying Bishop G7
is I'm unleashing this bishop and
essentially preventing Bishop E3 if
Bishop E3 is played that runs into
Knight G4 so white has to be a little
bit careful with the move order uh he
started with Pawn F3 which is very
typical essentially preparing Bishop E3
and I keep following my preparation I
take take and Bishop to G7 now one thing
I want to note is going into this game I
didn't really have much specific
preparation for my opponents really all
I knew is that he plays E4 and usually
goes into open Sicilians but by some
miracle I checked this variation
specifically it's such such a ridiculous
miracle that that I don't even remember
why I checked it before the game because
I had a very similar game uh about a
month ago in Norway that followed the
exact same moves actually threw a couple
of moves further after Bishop E3 Castle
Queen D2 and then Pawn A5 Pawn B3 I had
the same position against Grand Master
culottes at the kregero chest heard mint
and I recapped that game I'll leave a
link somewhere maybe you're above or
below but um in that game I didn't know
what to do and I spent maybe uh 10 to 15
minutes in this position trying to
figure things out
um I forget exactly what I played in
that game I think I played Bishop D7
with idea of Bishop C6
but for this game I had this position on
my computer right before the round
because I was checking to see what the
Improvement can be and I knew the main
line here is to play A4 so I blitzed it
out in this position and we're actually
following uh a Carlson carwana game I
believe Magnus was playing the white
pieces you can check here in the Masters
database
uh oh Carl uh carwan uh so many cars I
guess Carlson was actually playing the
black pieces and
um we followed the game for a few more
moves I'll leave the opening book open
my opponent played B4 I played Bishop to
E6
played Rook to C1 so so far we're
basically playing like the top players
in the world
um and then I played Pawnee 3 which
deviates from the Carlson game
um I think I just forgot
my specific prep uh even though I I
looked at the game shortly before the
round I wasn't sure between A3 and
Knight D7 I believe Knight D7 is the
main move here yeah this is what was
played in the The carwana Carlson game
and then that game went a different
route where eventually Fabiano went for
the the king side attack with the H Pawn
thrust
um but as we're gonna see in my game we
took a slightly different strategy and I
started with A3 and my opponent actually
just tried to punish this move right
away and maybe make me regret playing A3
before Knight D7 my opponent here played
Knight to B5 which I think is a very
nice move for whites because not only
does it pressure my A3 Pawn which is a
potential weakness even though I'm
trying to use it as a strength on the
queen side but there's also ideas for
white of playing Knight D4 and hitting
my Bishop on E6 which is just more of a
Target than really any useful piece
because C4 is now very well defended and
the move that I ended up playing in
response was Queen D7 understanding the
fact that I'm likely gonna concede the
bishop pair if white goes for the Knight
D4 in the trade but then at least my
queen can take back and I can avoid this
uh kind of ugly Pawn structure and my
plan with Queen D7 was to put the Rook
on CA and just try and have the best
squares as possible for my pieces so the
game continues from here Bishop E2 Rook
C8 and then here my opponent castled and
I was actually more scared of this move
Knight D4 after which I wasn't sure what
was I gonna play just because black
feels a little bit stuck here and
sometimes this is a problem as black
playing against some Roxy bind White's
controlling so much space and it's
really hard to maneuver the pieces when
you're just so cramped and I would have
felt very claustrophobic in this
position I think I was planning 98 and
like allowing this but maybe getting
some eventual Knight C7 and maybe B5 or
maybe getting the Knight to E6 someday
but uh I didn't have to worry about that
my opponent did castle and then I was
able to play Queen Yates so I'm
operating with less space but trying to
make the most of it with Queen Yates I
give the bishop a square to retreat and
I also have ideas with the queen which
we're in the sea uh very soon
so game continues Rook T1 Bishop D7
hitting the knights Knight moves to D4
and then I spent a long time before
playing my next move Bishop A4
and I'll admit that I was very tempted
after my opponent responded with Rook E1
I was really tempted to just go back to
D7 and off for a draw because I really
didn't like my position and I thought
maybe this would be one peaceful way of
just ending the game with some
repetition but then I decided instead of
repeating I have a just a better Square
for the bishop rather than going back to
D7 the move I liked the most was Bishop
C6 so I avoided repetition I did not
offer a draw I'm still trying to create
some chances and the point of Bishop to
C6 is eventually I want to play B6 and
Bishop B7 and just have a a more stable
home for the bishop where it's not in
the way of potential Knight D7 and 95
maneuvers
so my opponent plays Bishop F1 kind of a
waiting move but maybe preparing Queen
F2
I play Pawn B6 Queen F2 was played and
then I played Knight D7 so this is a
very typical move in accelerated dragon
and Mainline Dragon the knights helps
unleash the bishop and in many cases I
have ideas of playing 95 or if the
b-pawn ever moves I'd like to play
Knight C5 as well and in this position
there's actually a really funny line
that I'm a bit disappointed we didn't go
into but after the game my opponent told
me he also saw this funny line and he
was scared of it so I was really hoping
that he would take
I would take and then Pawn B5 and at
first it looks like White's winning a
pawn but I have a really cool move Rook
C5
sacking The Exchange and after takes
takes
I don't even get a pawn for it White's
just up a rook for a night here but I
think there's full positional
compensation because this bishop is just
a terrible piece I have ideas of Bishop
B2 and E5 and Bishop D4 or maybe
maneuver the Knight to D4 and black is
really just dominating the dark squares
in this position
so sadly we didn't go into that
I also should note that I don't have to
play Rook C5 I can also play Rook C8 and
if white takes the pawn there's a line
where White's Queen got stuck on B6 and
this would also I think offer nice
compensation for black
so instead of being materialistic and
trying to win a pawn my opponent played
a simple move Rook B1 and he told me
after the game that he knew that the
Rooks generally in Marazzi bind like to
be on C1 and B1 and I think he's very
correct in this regard and there's also
ideas now of flack lifting both Rooks to
the third rank ideas of Rook B3 Rook C1
and Rook C3 and really going after this
a pawn which for the time being only has
one Defender I Rook on eight
so I realized that I kind of have to
figure out a plan here I started with
Bishop to B7 just not allowing Bach to
ever take on C6 he responds with Rook to
C1 and here I took another kind of long
think trying to figure out what to do
because my Bishops are decently happy my
Knights
has one square on E5 but it doesn't
really attack anything because C4 is
defended and then there was a move that
came to mind which looked to be the most
interesting and that move involves the
queen and seems like the queen can't
really play a role in this position
because it's just stuck behind my pieces
but there is a move to generate some
plan is to move Queen to f8
and the idea of this move is essentially
twofold maybe even threefold I have
ideas of Bishop H6 attempting to trade
off White's best bishop and alleviate
the pressure on this diagonal there's
also ideas of playing some Bishop F6 or
Bishop E5 and then Queen G7 creating a
battery on the long diagonal
and then I said maybe threefold because
there's another idea here which I don't
think I was likely to go for but there
are a potential positions where F5 can
happen and the queen supports the pawn
and there's ways of trying to break down
White Center or maybe get some space on
the king side but uh with F5 I always
have to worry about 96 so it's not an
immediate idea for black here
so after I play Queen f8 my opponent
pretty quickly responded with Queen D2
simply preventing my idea with Bishop H6
and then I played Bishop to E5
so I'm essentially centralizing the
bishop and I want to bring my queen to
G7 I also had ideas of eventually
playing E6 and D5 which I thought is a
nice way to try and break down the
center and if I start with E6 in this
position I was a little bit scared of
Knight to B5 attacking the d-pawn so I
figured it's not a bad idea to over
defend the d-pawn so I can hopefully get
in this uh this E6 move
so here my opponent plays Rook B3 I play
Pawn E6 and this is where things are
about to get really really really crazy
because after Knight B5 it seems like
I'm losing a pawn and I realize that I'm
probably in trouble here but at least
I'm able to just create chaos in the
position and I'm just in time to play
the move Pawn to D5
and I played this and my opponent took a
long think because there's just so much
going on in this position my pawns
attacked twice it is defended once
there's options of taking with either
pawn and there's a alignment against the
D file so my Pawn is actually pinned on
D5 there's also ideas Upon A forehing
the bishop and there's tension on the C
file as well
so just so many things to address
and the move I was most scared of which
my opponent didn't play was Knight takes
A3 and I wasn't sure what I was going to
do against this move because my knight
is still loose on D7 I think I was going
to play Knight F6 and uh yeah be down
upon but maybe have some more pressure
in the center and I haven't had a chance
to analyze extensively with the engine
so I really don't know what the true
evaluation is here but I'll be curious
to do so so instead of taking on A3 my
opponent played Bishop H6 which is
another alternative here hitting my
queen provoking Queen E7 and then he
plays Pawn F4 and this is a very forcing
continuation my Bishop has to move I
decided to move to B2 which is the only
way to save my bishop and my Pawn except
I'm not really saving either because
white socks on B2 I lose my Bishop in
Pawn and even though white is now down
material there's some nasty threats on
the G7 Square Queen G7 is a main threat
and the position looks really really
scary at first glance but I do have a
way to defend I play Pawn F6 and at this
point I should note that we were both
getting pretty low on time uh this was
move 30 so we had 10 more moves to make
until getting an extra half hour and I
think we were both hovering around
uh maybe just less than 10 minutes like
seven eight minutes per side and here my
opponent really keeps trying to move
forward and get initiative and get
compensation for being down the exchange
he plays Pawn to E5 which uh makes the
idea of Knight T6 really terrifying
because this is a square I can't really
contest but when I saw this coming I had
an idea to get initiative by starting
with taking and after after takes I'm
really the first one to start throwing
punches here with the move Queen to H4
and my opponent told me after the game
that he missed this move essentially
hitting the bishop and delaying White's
plan of Knight D6 and White's forced to
play a defensive move here in the game I
was expecting Bishop E3 after which
maybe I have Queen E5 hitting the bishop
in Pawn so my opponent decided to play
Queen to D2 and then I snacked on E5 pod
I figured I would allow Knight D6 and
just remove the support of D6 my
opponent still goes in with the Knight
and it's still just really really
chaotic uh because my rook and Bishop
are attacked my knight is a loose piece
at the same time there's a lot of ideas
for me like I was trying to make ideas
of Knight G4 work or taking on C4
there's also pressure against A2 and all
ultimately I decided not to move my
Bishop not to move my Rook but play
um a very forcing counter-attack Rook
takes A2
sacking back material now I'm not
sacrificing the whole Rook because after
Queen A2 which was played I'm able to
take the bishop and even though these
things are still hanging I'm hitting the
Rook on C1
and at this point we were both falling
below five minutes and uh I don't think
either of us had a super clear idea what
was going on but we had to react move by
move so
play rookie one I respond with Knight G4
threatening mates and I was excited when
I saw this line from a distance because
the most natural looking move for white
is to play H3 hitting the knights and
now I have three things hanging my
knight bishop and Rook but there's a
really really nice move for blocked
counter-attack in this position if you
want to try and find it feel free to
pause the video but I can simply ignore
all the threats and play Queen F4
threatening mates on each two also
hitting the knights and I believe this
would simplify in Black's favor after
takes takes if we count the pawns it's
five on four and only black would have
winning chances here so I was hoping to
go into that
but that did not happen
uh instead of playing H3 my opponent
played the much stronger Pawn to G3 and
at first it looks like how does this
defend H2 but you have to see the whole
board the Queen on A2 has a long
distance relationship with this Pawn so
taking on H2 does not work for me and
now I still have to deal with this fork
and my time was getting very low and I
decided to go for a very insane line uh
starting with Queen G7 now there's a lot
going on here because the rook and
Bishop are still available for capture
but I'm very interested in just going
after the white king I really want to
play Queen D4 check and to first show
white can't take the Rook because after
Queen D4 the king will be forced to one
of these squares which is a line with
the bishop and yeah either Square I
would take the pawn and this is just
about game over uh yeah King H3 Knight
F2 not quite mate white has one legal
move but I'll be winning this position
so when I played Queen G7 I thought I
was being very clever
um but then it still gets very tricky
because
white doesn't take my Rook white takes a
bishop
and I didn't want to take back the
Knight because then my E6 Pawn Falls
even the move like Queen E2 hitting the
knights and then later capturing on E6 I
could be in a lot of trouble here so
after Knight takes B7 I really have to
go all out with my attack I start with
Queen D4 and after King H1 I bring my
rook in and even though I'm down a piece
I have a lot of scary threats between
Knight F2 and Rook F2 and it seemed
really really close to winning here but
White's still able to defend with the
move Queen to E2 essentially bringing
the queen closer to the king side
hitting the pawn and E6 and at this
point we are on move
40 actually Queen E2 was White's 40th
move so after this move my opponent got
an extra half hour and I have one more
move to make before I get more time and
the move I ended up playing was Knight
to F2 which is the most forcing move in
the position now after I played this I
briefly regretted having not seriously
considered Pawn E5 and this is almost
winning for black because there's an
almost Unstoppable threat of Rook F2
like for example Bishop G2 Rook F2 Queen
D1 Rook D2 would be a winning position
actually I should play it out until mate
Queen C1 I would get the famous
Queen sacrifice leading to smother mates
this would be a very satisfying win but
uh yeah the reason why E5 actually
doesn't work here is because there's
this move Pawn H3 and once I realized
this I was happy I I went for a knight
F2 rather than E5
um because after Pawn H3 Rook F2 doesn't
work due to Queen G4 so I'm pretty sure
Knight F2 was the right decision but
after he plays King G2 I realized that I
don't really have a great alternative
other than just returning to G4 and I'm
essentially offering repetition with
this move but because we got an extra
half hour he had a lot more time to
think and he took his time here and he
played the move Queen takes E6 which at
first looks really scary for black
because my king is quite open but after
I played the move King h8 like King is
actually really safe here because he
doesn't have any checks on this diagonal
thanks to my Knights covering the E5
Square
and from this position I'm still
threatening Rook F2 or queen F2 and it
seems still really really scary for
white and he played one of the only
defensive moves here rooked E2
and then I go in with Queen D1 and at
this point I thought I'm very very close
to winning because I'm threatening
checkmates in one move Queen takes F1
and if he plays a natural looking rookie
one then I have Queen H3 and this is
force mate regardless of where the king
moves King G1 runs into the eventual
Queen H2 mate and if King H3 then I have
Knight F2 and queen H5 with checkmates
so white has to be really really careful
and he found what I'm pretty sure is the
only move to survive in this position
essentially to abandon the bishop and
play King to H3
and I just lost internet connection oh
no my internet
time to drink some more Icelandic water
hey we're reconnected
so after King H3
I still thought I was really close to
winning and when we got to this position
I calculated uh what seemed to be a
really nice line is Queen takes F1
King takes G4 Queen F3 check King h3back
and then Rook F5
and at first it looks like I'm gonna
eventually deliver mate and my initial
calculation was after Rook F5 there's a
couple checks Queen E8 King G7 Rook E7
King H6 and I thought if we get to this
position my king finds safety on H6
there's no Queen f8 because my Rook
still controls f8 and Rook H5 should be
unstoppable if he plays a move like
rookie 5 I have Queen F1 King H4 G5 King
G4 and I'm pretty sure there's mate
there
is there mate queen of three
let me just play it out I feel like I'm
making a mess here with all these arrows
so I was calculating Queen F1 here here
here
Rook F5
Queen E8 King G7 rookie seven okay not a
mouse slip Rook E7 King H6 threatening
this and after this
uh this this
oh no I was I was calculating uh Queen
H5 not mating but winning The Rook on E5
and then there's this wait don't I'm
getting needed okay we didn't go into
that but we didn't go into even the
start of this variation and let me show
why
um
what happens
yeah so King G4
and the reason why I didn't play Rook F5
here is actually something much simpler
white can give Perpetual check
after Queen E8 King G7 Queen E7 and if I
move to H6 there's Queen E3 forcing a
queen trade and at the very least white
has a draw maybe white can fight on in
that other line although I probably had
some perpetual
so long story short basically what
happened is once we got to this position
I realized my my winning ideas don't
work with the eventual Rook F5 so I
decided to just repeat and after King H3
I gave a check on H5 and very quickly we
agreed to a draw given that the king
can't go back to G1 because Queen F1 and
if I don't repeat that I'm down at night
and uh I would yeah I would probably
lose if if I don't keep giving checks so
it was a long crazy game uh there's a
lot of takeaways from this game a lot I
have to study and maybe check with the
engine to see what opportunities were
missed what blunders were made but uh it
was really well thought I think my
opponent played very well and he was on
the verge of winning so I'm thankful to
draw this
um it did seem like I was close to
winning maybe at some point but just
couldn't find find the way
so yeah after this game I had how many
points
or out of seven
now the term is actually over now I'm
recording this after the tournament's
over but I don't want to spoil anything
do stay tuned for the final two Recaps I
had some really really fun games in the
last two rounds so what more to say
keep liking subscribing commenting and
I'll see you guys soon